مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
حكومه افغانستان تعلن مقتل ثلاثه مهاجمين
واصابات في صفوف اجانب في الهجوم على فندق
يدوم صينيين
خطط لانشاء قدرات وطنيه مميزه في
الرادارات
رئيسه شركه الصناعات العسكريه السعوديه
يقول بان التركيز القادمه سيكون للمسيرات
والراداررات
مركز الارصاد في السعوديه يواصل تحذيره من
استمرار فرصه هطول امطار غزيره على مكه
وجده
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
مؤشر وسوق الاسهم السعوديه كسروا حاجز
العشره الاف نقطه ويسجل ادنى مستوى له منذ
ابريل 2021
ارتفاعه اعداد سياح السعوديه الى سته
ملايين خلال ربع الثاني من العام الجاري
حياكم الله اعلنت حكومه افغانستان مقتل
ثلاثه مهاجمين وتسجيل اصابات في صفوف
اجانب في الهجوم على فندق يضم صينيين
وكانت قوه الامن
الافغانيه قد اغلقت كل الشوارع المحيطه
بالفندق الذي وقع فيهم تجاره وتبادل
لاطلاق النار واضافه ان قوه الامن حاول
الدخول الفندق المستهدف من المباني
المجاوره لهم مشيرا الى ان المنطقه قريبه
من القصر الرئاسي ومن قرات البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
الينا هنا
احمد سيد اهلا بك مع سيد احمد
بدايه كيف يمكن تقييم هذا الهجوم هل
استهدف بالفعل
دبلوماسينا صينيين ام لا هو استهدف يعني
فئه اخرى ليست الدبلوماسيه لكنها تقيم
داخل المنطقه الخضراء وداخل البعثات
الدبلوماسيه همم المحيطه بهذه المنطقه
اليوم في كابل استهدف كان يقيم في الفندق
رجال اعمال ومستشارين ومهندسين همم الاسود
رجال الاعمال الصينيين اعتدوا على السكن
في هذا الفندق يعتبر ضيافه الصينيين
بالنسبه لهم بحكم استثماراتهم واا اعمالهم
وتجاراتهم داخل افغانستان في مختلف
المناطق
جاءت من النجوم الواقعه اول انفجارين في
بدايه الهجوم ومن ثم بدا اطلاق النار بين
الطالبان والمسلحين فجار انفجار داخل
الفندق
في البدايه وهم يتم حدث اطلاق نار
[موسيقى]
بين المهاجمين وحكومه الطالبان من ثم اعلن
الطالبان قبل قليل انتهت بمقتل المسلحين
الثلاثه واصابه هل يمكن ان نربط بين ما
حدث اليوم
وبين الزياره التي قام بها السفير الصيني
يوم امس يوكيل وزاره الخارجيه في حكومه
طالبان
والطالب الذي تقدم به لتامين همم المنطقه
المحيطه
بالسفاره الصينيه في في كابول
ومعلومات
هجوم قد يحدث على السفاره الصينيه واحد
المواطنين الصينيين لذلك يوم امس همم طلب
منه وكيل وزاره الخارجيه همم بتوفيره
وتكثيف الامن في المحيط السفاره الصينيه
والتوجه بشكل اكثر
لحمايه الامنيه للسفاره والبيت
الدبلوماسيه همم
ان لدى الصينيين من الهجوم الذي استهدف
قبل عشره ايام من القائم بعمل السفاره
الباكستانيه واصيب احد حراس الشخصيين ااا
داعش نفذ تلك العمليه الاسبوع الماضي كان
وكان تحاول اغتيال القائم بالاعمال ولكن
نصيب حارثه الشخصي لذلك كمان تبقى مهاجمه
ايضا حتى قبل شهرين تقريبا الان السفاره
الروسيه وقتلت فيها همم اثنين من البيعه
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه في في هذا الهجوم
وايون داعش كانت متهم ويساله هنا عن همم
طالبان هل اصبحت همم هل يمكن القول بانها
مخترقه ربما من الداخل وبالتالي هناك
سهوله في الوصول الى البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الى المستثمرين التجاره الذين يقيمون مثلا
في فنادق داخل البعثات الدبلوماسيه كما
حدث اليوم في القصير هل يمكن توصيفها بهذا
الشكل
منه طالبان مخترقه
بخصوصا من داعش
مخترقه طالبا في هذا ثاني لو نتذكر حتى
الان هذه ثلاث ثالث او حدثتين على بيتها
الدبلوماسيه هذه الحادثه على مواطنين
اجانب في الدوله همم لو نتذكر كذلك قبل
عده اشهر اغتيال رحمه الله حقاني احد اكبر
علماء طالبان داخل نفس المنطقه الخضراء في
وزير اكبر خان في منطقه وزير الطرحانيه
المنطقه الخضراء قتل وهو الذي عدد كبير من
الحرس من القوات الخاصه للطالبان ولكن تم
اغتياله بوجود داخل مدرسته الدينيه قبل
ايام الاستخبارات في طالبان قبضت على
المخطط لهذه العمليه وكان من ضمنهم حاجه
بشير حاجه بشير كان موظف في القصر الرئاسي
في رئاسه الوزراء كان الموظف رئاسه
الوزراء حسب المعلومات التي السابقه
يقال بان عمه احد مسؤولين وزاره الدفاع
السابقه وان قبض على هذا الشخص ويطلق بكيت
الضمان وكفاله من علمه ومن ثم خطه
الاغتيال رحمه الله حقاني وق ايوه اعترف
بانه هو من مخطط همم لعمليه
موجود كما تقول بين طالبان وبين داعش
وبانه هناك اختراقات في صفوف طالبان من
قبل داعش لماذا تحديدا يتم استهداف
البعثات همم الدبلوماسيه مثلا الروسيه
الباكستانيه الصينيه اتذكر ايضا حتى قبل
سنه او اكثر من الان تم استهداف حافله كان
همم يعني كان فيها مواطنين صينيين اعتقد
على الحدود الباكستانيه الافغانيه
ولكن الحدود نعم نعم
لكن هذه الاختراقات الامنيه من داعش
يعني يطلع لي داعش تريد ان تحاول ان توجه
رساله لمن داخل افغانستان وحتى دول
المنطقه بانها هي متواجده داخل افغانستان
لديها قوى لديها القدره على زعزعه
الاستقرار في افغانستان محاوله
محاوله الامن ثقه الشاب بطالبان بشكل
اوضحها وانها قادر على فعل كل شيء وصلت
الى البيتات الدبلوماسيه وصلت الى كبار
اعضاء حركه الطالبان هي وصلت الاستجار
ومستثمرين اليوم
اختراق
الاعمال المستثمرين وخصوصا المسلمين في
مجال المعادن في افغانستان
اعتقد انه داعش هي دائما
تخلق نوع من القلق لدى البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
هذا الفندق اليوم الذي حدثت فيه طبعا هذه
هذه الحادثه بالانفجارين والاستهداف ايضا
باطلاق النار هل هل هذا الفندق قريب اولا
من السفاره الصينيه وهل هو اصلا داخل
المنطقه الخضراء ومنطقه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه بحيث انه هذا الفندق هناك
حراسه مشدده على الاقل حول هذه المنطقه
همم شهرنا وهي من المنطقه الخضراء قريبه
من القصر الرئاسي تبعد عن السفاره الصينيه
وحتى القصر الرئاسي مسافه كيلوين ونصف الى
ثلاثه كيلو
[موسيقى]
هذا يعني هي المنطقه يعني بالطبع هي منطقه
همم
يتواجد بها تواجد دمني مكثف ولكن هذه
الاختراقات همم
تبدا في داخل بعض القياده بعض المؤسسات
الامنيه داخل طالبان في عدم استطاعتها حتى
حمايه البيئه او المقيمين الاجانب همم
الاضاحات
كان معي هنا في الاستديو الصحفي الافغاني
احمد سيد شكرا جزيلا لك
ومستشفى طبعا الطوارئ في كابو متابعته
لهذا الموضوع الذي بدانا به نشره الرابعه
مستشفى الطوارئ في كابول يعلن عن مقتل
ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه 10 شخصا في حادثه
الهجوم على فندق يسكنه همم اذا في
السعوديه كشفت الهيئه العامه للصناعات
العسكريه عن انفاق اكثر من خمسه مليارات
على
حوافز تعزيز صناعه العسكريه خلال العامين
الماضي منها ثلاثه فاصله ثلاثه من عشره
مليون للبحث والتطوير الصناعي العسكري كما
جرى توزيع قرابه مليارين ريال على شركات
عده منها الشركات السعوديه
والشركه السعوديه لصناعه العسكريه الثانيه
ولكن لما نرى على مدى ال
10 سنوات من تاسيس الهيئه الى 2030 اتوقع
ان يكون للقطاع حوالي 95
مليار ريال حجم مساهمه القطاع في الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بحلول 2030
خططنا ان شاء الله ان يكون فيه 35 مليار
ريال مساهمه في الايرادات غير النفطيه
حلول عام 2030
نتوقع ان شاء الله استثمارات مباشره في
القطاع فوق ال 37 مليار ان شاء الله
ومثلها ايضا في الابحاث والتطوير
مش هيكون له مساهمه مهمه في خلق فرص
وظيفيه
لا يقل عن 100 الف فرصه وظيفيه منها 40000
مباشره
لشبابنا وبناتنا و60000 فرصه وظيفيه غير
اعلنت شركه السعوديه للصناعات العسكريه
سامي انها ستركز في السنوات المقبله على
الانظمه المسيره واجهزه الرادار والامن
الالكتروني وقال رئيس التنفيذي للشركه
وليد ابو خالد خلال منتدى الموازنه
بالرياض ان الصناعات العسكريه غير
الماهوله هي المستقبل وان المملكه ستركز
عليها
اذا نظرنا عالميا على على التحول وعلى
التقدم في صناعه العسكريه نرى ان الانظمه
الغير ماهوله هو مستقبل الصناعات العسكريه
الانظمه الغير ماهوله قد تكون طائره بدون
طيار قد يكون مركبه بدون قائد مركبه او
قارب بدون قبطان فهذه التقنيه نعمل عليها
جادين واظن بتكون همم
مهمه جدا ومركز عليها نركز على انظمه
الاستشعار مثل الرادارات وباذن الله يوجد
خطط لانشاء قدرات وطنيه مميزه في
الرادارات
وصل مركز السعوديه للارصاد اصدارات
تحذيراتي مع تزايدي فرصه طول امطار تصل
الى المستوى الغزير في منطقه مكه والتي
تتزايد معها احتماليه جريان السيول
واشاهده المنطقه الواقعه غرب السعوديه
حاله مطريه بكميات وصلت الى 25 ملي متر في
جده واربعه ملم في منطقه الطائف خلال
الاربعاء 24 ساعه الماضيه
من جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سعود
الخلف سعود مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض اليوم فعلا كلنا
الاجوف في جده كيف
تبدو الحاله المطريه التي مرت بها جده
ايضا ليله البارحه صباح اليوم ايضا كيف
تقيمها
المطريه يوم امس من الساعه العاشره مساءا
واستمرت حتى صباح هذا اليوم طبعا الحاله
المطريه توزعت على احياء جده همم تقريبا
نستطيع ان نقول بشكل متساوي همم كان هنالك
طبعا التحذيرات والتنبيهات المبكره من قبل
المركز الوطني للارصاد كان له دور كبير في
همم ان يوجه الجهاد المعنيه ياخذ الحيطه
والحذر والتجاوب الكبير ايضا من الجهات
المعنيه سواء من الامانه الدفاع المدني
وحتى همم
ساهم بشكل كبير في ان همم تمر هذه الحاله
المطريه بسلام لماذا نقول همم يعني كان
لها دور كبير لانه الامانه نشرت الياتها
ومعداتها همم بشكل كامل على اكثر المناطق
التي تتحدث فيها المياه التعليم بادر في
وقت مبكر بتعليق الدراسه حضو والاعتماد
عليها عن بعد مما ساهم في عدم وجود ازدحام
للحركه المروريه بسبب يعني همم ذهاب
الطلاب والطالبات الى همم مقر الدراسه هذه
الامور سهلت بشكل كبير حركه المعدات همم
للوصول الى المواقع ايضا كان هنالك اغلاق
للانفاذ حتى لا يكون هنالك تكدس ويعني
صعوبه في الحركه للوصول الى هذه المناطق
همم هنالك كثير من الامور وايضا الامانه
التي وضعت خطه همم موسميه لموسم همم
الامطار كانت مساهمه بشكل كبير كثير من
التفاصيل همم نايفه سماحث لي سيكون معي
الاستاذ محمد البقمي يعطينا ما الذي تم
يوم ليله البارحه وحتى همم الان وماذا
سيكون خلال الايام القادمه يعطيك العافيه
استاذ محمد همم مرت الحلقه المطريه بسلام
ولله الحمد ما الذي قمت به من ليله او حتى
هذه اللحظه الحقيقه توجد لجنه دائمه في
امانه محافظه جده لجنه الامطار هذه اللجنه
تضع خطه اا خطه هذه همم موسميه يتم تفعيل
الخطه مع دخول موسم الامطار همم الخطه هذه
تتركز على توزيع المعدات والاليات
والافراد على نطاق 16 بلديه فرعيه و13
مركز اسناد في مدينه جده طبعا بعد تلقي
همم
التنبيهات من همم مركز الوطني للارصاد
تباشر هذه الفرق اعمالها ومع هطول الحاله
المطريه تبدا اعمال سحب المياه من الاحياء
ومناطق اللي تتجمع فيها المياه طيب الخطه
الموسميه الخاصه بمواجهه الحالات المطريه
همم ما الذي تعتمدون عليه
الحقيقه تعتمد على الخطه على توزيعها على
جميع المناطق اللي تتكرر فيها ااا ما
تجمعات المياه وما يكون فيها شبكه لتصريف
مياه الامطار فيتم توزيعها هذه المعدات
والافراد على هذه المناطق بالتحديد ايضا
الهدف الرئيسي في هذه الخطه هو تحرير
المحاور الرئيسيه والطرق العامه في
المدينه بحيث تستمر الحركه ولا تتوقف في
المدينه في حالات بطاريه سابقه كنت معنا
استاذ محمد وتحدثنا عن همم التعامل مع همم
يعني تصريف المياه وكنا همم يعني رحنا
الملاحظه باعتماتكم على الصهاريج والمعدات
وذكرته بان هنالك مشاريع ما الذي تم على
هذه المشاريع صحيح همم
منظر همم الصهاريج ممكن شيء مزعجه واحنا
نقدر هذا الشيء لكن احنا مضطرين ل- يعني
في هذه الفتره حتى احتمال المشاريع همم
طبعا هذه يتم استخدامها
هو المضخات يتم استخدامها في المناطق اللي
ما بتوجد فيها شبكه لتصريف مياه الامطار
المدينه همم
فيما يخص المشاريع اذا كان ضيف لسه موجود
يا سعود انا ما اعرف اعتقد انه راح
طيب نبي نسال عن هذه المشاريع
في المياه متى من الممكن ان تنتهي هذه
المشاريع وكما ذكر قبل قليل انه منظر هذه
الظاهره وغيره ليست يعني مناظر همم محبب
مشاهدتها يعني فما تنتهي هذه المشاريع كم
ستغطي كذلك من همم نسب تصريف المياه في في
جده
طيب اعطونا وقت بس يا نايف اعطيك دقيقه يا
سعودي استاذ محمد نفس السؤال المشاريع
المشاريع وفي دقيقه متى ستتم انت كانت بان
الصهاريج يعني منظرها غير جيد ونحن نتطلع
الى انتهاء هذه المشاريع متى ستتم ما الذي
تم حتى الان لهذه المشاريع مشاريع تصريف
الامطار حتى الان تم الانتهاء من تنفيذ
عشره مشاريع يجري الان تنفيذ 10 مشاريع
اخرى حزمه مشاريع قادمه همم متى تنتهي ان
شاء الله يعني مع الانتهاء تغطيه الشبكه
في المدينه حوالي
75% من همم من المدينه تحتاج الى شبكه وان
شاء الله مع احتمال لها ان شاء الله سيتم
الاستغناء عن هذه الصهاريج بطيء تحديد
موعد ما عندي موعد لا لا للاسف ما عندي
موعد شكرا
يعطيك العافيه هذه كانت اجابه الاستاذ
محمد ومنوه بان لا زالت الحاله المطريه
والتنبيهات من المركز الوطني لا زالت
مستمره حتى الخميس القادم فنرجوا من
الجميع اخذ الحيطه والحذر
يعني الاستمرار بهذا الوعي الذي شاهدناه
اليوم شكرا انت وضيفك الكريم من جدا مراسل
العربيه سعد الخلف شكرا لك يا سعود
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل
الموارد البشريه السعوديه تعلن اعتمادا
منصه قوه لتوفيق عقود عمل المواطنين
والمقيمين
الماسه ثمينه يشيع نورها من قلب الرياض
اكثر من
115,000 متر مربع على طريق الملك خالد
وطريق الملك عبد الله بجوار مول جوهره
الرياض ايقونه التسوق في المملكه الماسه
تفرد باقتنائها
هذه نوف الاهتمام بصحتها اهم اولوياتها
جاء موعد فيتامين اللي ما تلقاه الا من
بره الحين تركيز 200 مل ولا 100 ليش لازم
ادفع اكثر عشان توصل الشحنه اسرع في حد
يساعدني
رحله الانتظار اسبوع اسبوعين الين تجينا
فيتامينات اللي يمكن ما تكون في احسن
حالتها لكن الوضع الحين غير نفس صار عندها
اون لاين صيدله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الجماعه في بلدنا فيها شيء ميزها يا سيدي
على لمه اهل الحجاز لقمه من تو على صفاتهم
ولا الحنيث تحت غيوم الجنوب وسط جبالها
والله على صحن جديد اجمعنا في نجد الاحباب
وما تدري تمدح اللمه ولا المكبوس ما نسمه
هواء على بحر الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعام المميز
حاضر معنا فيكي الجمعه الحلوه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد نعود الى الملف الذي
بدانا به نشره الرابعه وهو الهجوم الذي
استهدف فندق يقيم به سكان صينيون ويلتحقوا
بنا من كابو المراسل العربيه عبد الله
نادر عبد الله مرحبا بك معي في نشرات
الرابعه من الرياض عبد الله حتى هذه
اللحظه مستشفى طوارئ كابول يتحدث عن ثلاثه
قتلى عن 18 اصابه هل من جديد في هذه
الارقام ومن الذي تم استهدافه في هذا
الهجوم حتى الان
ااا يعني الفندق هذا يقع في قلب العاصمه
كابول وعاده ينزل فيه المواطنين الصينيون
وقد اعترف ذبح الله مجاهد في تغريده بان
العمليات التصفيه انتهت بمقتل ثلاثه من
المهاجمين ولم يقتل في هذه العمليات وفي
هذا الهجوم احد من الاجانب وهذا يعني ان
هذا الفندق ينزل فيه الاجانب وهمم اضافه
ذبح الله مجاهد في تغريده بان اثنين من
الاجانب اصيب في هذا الهجوم وذلك بعد ما
القى بنفسهما من المبنى العلمي همم هذه
الاصابات التي همم نقل او انت نقلت الى
المستشفى القريبه هذه الاصابات من
المواطنين الافغان في الفندق ينزل فيه
الافغان وكذلك المواطنون الصينيون وغيرهم
من الاجانب يعني
المواطنين الذين قانون هذا الفندق
بحسب المعلومات
بحسب بت
غريده ليس هناك قتلى بين الاجانب وخاصه
الصينيون همم بينهم همم
اصيب اثنان والذين القيا بنفسهما من
المنزل العلوي بحسب تعبيري ذبيح الله
مجاهد واصفا هذا الهجوم بانه نفذه اعداء
طالبنا اعداء الحكومه الحاليه الان انتهت
العمليات التصويريه بحسب ذبحو الله مجاهد
وبحسب انا اقترب من هذا الفندق همم ما
يقارب يعني 200 متر في منطقه شهر او ليست
هناك الان اشتباكات وليست هناك همم رصاص
بين الجانبين الا ان الشوارع وطرقات
المؤديه الى هذه المنطقه المسدوده لحد
الان وب- وعاده همم تقوم السلطات والقوات
الامنيه بمحوي اثاري مثل هذه العمليات
وتعود بعد ذلك الحياه الى طبيعتها همم
العاديه اشكرك جزيلا الشكر مراسل العربيه
من كابول عبد الله نادر شكرا جزيلا لك حتى
اعلانات وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه في السعوديه ان اعتمادها
وتوثيق عقود العمل السعوديين والوافدين
يكون عبر منصه قوى الالكترونيه حيث تتيح
المنصه الوصول الى جميع الخدمات قطاع
العمل الالكترونيه هذا تهدف الوزاره من
خلال تلك الاشتراكات الى توفير الحمايه
لاطراف التعقديه ورفع مستويات الامتال
لسداد الاجور وزياده جاذبيه السوق العمل
السعودي
علينا هنا في الاستديو المهندس فيصل
الاضفيان الوكيل المساعد بوزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه لشؤون العمل
المهندس في الصالحيه
خلينا نعرف اولا عن هذا القرار قرار توثيق
العقود في منصه قوه ما الذي سيضيفه الى
العلاقه التعاقديه الى الطرفين
في البدايه خلينا بس ابتدي من قرار مجلس
الوزراء رقم 195 واللي او كان لوزاره
الموارد البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه
اداره العلاقه التعاقديه من التوثيق حتى
الانتهاء الوزاره اليوم طبعا طورت عده
خدمات على منصه قوه تتالق
باداره العلاقه التعاقديه وتحسينها سواء
توثيق العقود انهاء العلاقه التعاقديه
كافه الخدمات كم منظومه كامله مع هذا ال-
ال- الخدمات والتطوير اللي تم استر طبعا
قرار معالي الوزير رقم 75,000 و506 القاضي
بالزام المنشات بتوثيق عقود العاملين
لديها سواء سعوديا نوافدين على منصه قوه
طبعا هذا منطلق تحسين العلاقه التعاقديه
وحفظ الحقوق لكل الطرفين صاحب العمل ما
كانت ملتقى من اول هذه العقود بين الطرفين
بمعنى انه لو همم لو انا صاحب المنشا
وعندي همم يعني شخص يعمل عندي في المؤسسه
ففي عقل بيني وبينه والتامينات الاجتماعيه
وحتى وزاره الموارد البشريه يعني عندكم
يكون هذا العقد موجود موثق الشيء اللي
اضفت قوه اليوم ممتاز الكلام جدا جميل
اليوم احنا عندنا اليوم الخدمه
الالكترونيه مطلق على منصه قوه التي تتكلم
عن همم توثيق العقود اليوم متاح لصاحب
العمل على ممارسه قوى ان يوثق عقد اساسها
كم رجل مسبقا يعني عقد ساري ممكن يعكس على
منصه قوى ويضع تاريخ مباشره بناء تاريخ
المباشره السابق وكذلك من وصلات الاجور او
يكون عقد جديد همم اليوم في تكامل ما بين
وزاره الموارد البشريه والمؤسسه العامه
للتنميه الاجتماعيه سواء بمنصه قوه او مدد
الحمد لله تم الانتهاء في تقريبا شهر هجوم
العام الحالي من نقل كافه العقود اللي
كانت موثقه مسبقا على منصه مده الى منصه
قوى اليوم اصبحت ملخص
ممتاز في اسئله يعني خلينا نقول افتراضيه
صح التعبير لو في مثلا شخص انت يعني همم
تبغى همم
السعوديه
تستقبل العمل عندك وانت صاحب هل يستطيع
هذا العامل ان يوثق العقد الموجود اللي
بينك وبينه خارج السعوديه قبل ان ياتي
السعوديه وبالتالي ما يصير في اي مشاكل في
قصه الاجور ممتاز سواء حقيقه جدا رائع
استاذنا في اليوم هذا من احد الخطط اللي
احنا نعمل عليه في وزاره الموارد البشريه
ان يتم توثيق عقد العامل قبل وصوله
للمملكه تطرقت استاذناها في اليوم لحمايه
الاجور اليوم عندنا مبادره جدا مهمه تتعلق
بحمايه الاجور الحمد لله نسبه الالتزام
جدا فيها عاليه ومتابعه عند المقابله
وزاره الموارد البشريه الى ضمان حصول
العاملين على حقوقهم في التي تتعلق
بالاجره طبعا همم تستطيع انك تعدل همم
مثلا بعد انتهاء فتره التجربه لو بيزيد
مبلغ او بيصير في اي ميزات وغيره
اليوم فتحنا احنا في منصه قوى لصاحب العمل
تحديد فتره التجربه بالعمل طبعا بما مواد
نظام العمل اللي هي 53
انما ما تتجاوز 90 يوم ولا يحق لك طلبك
اكثر من فتره تجربه موافقه الطرفين اليوم
حتى لو قمت بتوثيق العقد ما بين العام
وصاحب العمل اذا اتفق الطرفين على تعديل
العقد لهم العقد ويستطيع لو كان في شخص
ايضا
في عقدنا مع جهه مثلا وكان راتبه موجود
مثلا في العقد 1,000 ريال خلينا نقول وهو
كان ياخذ مثلا اربع الى ثلاثه الاف ريال
من هذه المنشئه بحي انه العلاقه التعاقديه
مع انتهت خلاص هل يحق لانه يطالب همم
يعني بنهايه الخدمه او خلينا نقول همم
يعني ان هذه العلاقه التعاقديه بناء على
المبلغ اللي كان يستلمه الاربعه الاف والا
على 1000 ريال اللي موجود في العقد ممتاز
استاذ نايف اليوم همم ما احنا بحاجه لن
ننتظر ان العامل تنتهي علاقت على صاحب
العمل عشان طالب بحقوق اليوم العامل صاحب
العمل كلاما النظام كفى الله حقوقهم في
اليوم العامل اذا صرف لها اجر غير الاجر
متفق عليها صاحب العمل والملتقى العامل
حتى اثناء العلاقه التعاقديه التقدم الينا
فيه النظام دعوه اذا كان اقل اليوم همم
همم نسعى احنا في مبادئ في التشهد نحنا
نحل نزاع بينهم بموجب العقد اللي بينهم في
حال عدم الاتفاق ويحاله الموضوع لان
المحاكم العمال بناءا لا يتمرق قرار
اشكرك جزيلا شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات كل
هذه التفاصيل ولها حضورك معي هنا في
الاستديو المهندس فيصل الضيان الوكيل
المساعد في وزاره الموارد البشريه
والتنميه الاجتماعيه لشؤون العمري شكرا
جزيلا لك شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
اغلق سوق الاسهم السعوديه جلسه اليوم
وتراجعا بنسبه بلغت 1.4% بهبوط وصل الى
150 نقاط وذلك عند ادنى مستوى لهم منذ
ابريل 2021 وكان مؤشر السوق ترجع خلال
جلسه اليوم بنحو 190 نقطه ليصل الى ادنى
نقطه عند
9950 نقطه قبل ان يقل ليس من خزائره ويغلق
عند 10,000
و 33 نقطه
ينضم لنا هنا في الاستديو الخبير
الاقتصادي تامر السعيد زي تامر اهلا وسهلا
بك
حياكم
من سنتين تقريبا اول مره نستضيف الحديث عن
الانخفاضات اللي تحدث في سوق الاسهم
السعوديه دائما نتكلم عن الهبوط عن عفوا
الارتفاع والاسود بالارتفاع اليوم لماذا
هذا الهبوط بهذا الشكل
اول كانت الامور جدا ممتازه وكانت الاسواق
قويه وكانت الظروف مختلفه تماما اليوم
احنا عندنا ادوات استثماريه اخرى اصبحت
تنافس تنافس في العائد ما يقدم وسوق
الاسهم وبالتالي المستثمرين في اسواق
المال بداوا يطلبون اعلى ليتماشى مع
الادوات الاخرى خلينا نقول انه اليوم
اسعار الفائده ارتفعت بشكل كبير خلال
العام 22 بسبب مكافحه التضخم ومحاولات
البنوك المركزيه التدخل اليوم او هذا
الاسبوع عندنا اربعه او خمسه بلوك مركزيه
عندها اعلانات فيما يخص اسعار الفائده
وصلت اسعار الفائده تقريبا 6% هذه اعداد
امنه تعطي عائد بمقدار 6% اليوم اصبحت
الخيارات امام مستثمرين هم ان يتجه ويحصل
على 6% كعائد امن خالي من المخاطر تقريبا
او انه يتجه الى السوق الماليه المتذبذبه
وبالتالي يحاول ان يحقق عائد بمقدار 10
ونصف او 11% وهو متوسط عوائد اسواق المال
للسنوات ال 15 الماضي فا اه وفاضل بين
العائدين العائد الافضل هناك نقطه بس
اخيرا انه اليوم التراجع هذا يفسر بانه
المستثمرين اصبحوا يطلبون عائد اكبر من
السوق بمقارنه العوائد الاخرى اللي تحققها
الاصول دائما السوق وانعكاس الاقتصاد او
يعني هذه هي علاقه خلينا نقول طرديه بينهم
الاقتصاد السعودي اليوم يمر بازهى بمراحل
تاريخيه تقريبا يعني النساء بالنمو عندما
فاصله ثمانيه لاول مره
ناتج المحليه كسرت اليوم دولار وارقام
كبيره فائض في الميزانيه ايضا حتى كذلك
لكن الوضع في سوق الاسهم السعوديه لا يشبه
هذا الوضع او خلينا نقول الانخفاضات لا
تزال مستمره وشكله يعني رايحه الانخفاضات
في النزول لانه في عوامل اساسيه خلي يقول
في قراءه الاسواق في متوسطات وانماذج
تتحرك فيها الاسواق من حيث الارقام معتمد
عليها المستثمرين هذا اللي يحصل الان هو
خصم يطلب والمستثمرين حتى يحققون العائد
المطلوب همم استثماريا على استثماراتهم
خيراتهم الاستثماريه واحنا اصبحنا قريبين
من هذا المنطقه كثير من الاسهم الكبرى
المتاثره بالاقتصاد اصبحت تعطي عواء
تتجاوز في بعضها ما تقدم ولا ادوات الاكثر
اعمالا فهذه نقطه مهمه لازم ناخذها بعين
الاعتبار في الجهه الاخرى السوق مراه
الاقتصاد نعم ولكنه لا ينعكس بشكل مباشر
على همم يعني السوق يسبق حركه الاقتصاد
وبالتالي يتراجع الذي حصل هو تراجع يعني
مبرر بسبب وجود الادوات الاخرى
الاستثماريه الاخرى بالاضافه الى ارتفاع
التكاليف في الاقراض بالنسبه للشركات
على اسباب اخرى يعني ممكن تكون مش رئيسيه
لكنها احد الاسباب على على كثره
الاكتتابات اللي موجوده على السندات اللي
حصلت خلال الفتره الماضيه قديش هذه يعني
همم
كتابات هي جزء من السوق المشاركين هم هم
اصحاب الاختيار اما ان يشارك في الاكتتاب
ام لا نعم ياخذ جزء من السيوله صحيح لكن
الادوات الاخرى زي ما تفضلت الادوات
الاخرى اللي هي الصكوك وغيرها هي احد
الادوات التي اصبحت تعطي عائد مغري
للمستثمرين عشان كده وبالتالي هو يذهب
اليها عوضا عنه
نسبه الودائع الزمنيه في تقرير البنك
المركزي الشهر الاخير نامت بمقدار يعني
يعدل اعلى من ديسمبر 2019 بقيمه 60 مليار
ريال 15 45 مليار للهيئات الحكوميه
الهيئات
الماليه 15 مليار كانت من الافراد
والشركات فاليوم الادوات الاخرى اصبحت
اكثر جاذبيه او تعطي عائد افضل من الادوات
والسلام
على حضورك معي دائما في نشره الرابعه
الخبير الاقتصاديه ثامر السعيد شكرا لك
نبهات منصه حاضرين الخاصه بحضور مونديال
قطر جميع المسافرين اليها
انه سيتم اعاده المسافرين الذين لا
يستوفون متطلبات الدخول من المقيمين
والمواطنين
[موسيقى]
كما دعت الهيئه العامه للنقل في السعوديه
الراغبين في المغادره الى قطر عبر المنفذ
البري دعتهم للتاكد من وجود حجز مسبق وذلك
لضماني نهائي اجراءات السفر بشكل سلس كما
اشارت الهيئه على حسابي على تويتر بان
خدمه الحجز الترددي بالحفلات متاحه للحجز
مجانا وبشكل الكتروني
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو المتحدث باسم
الهيئه العامه للنقل صالح الزويد سيد صالح
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشات الربيع
من الرياض حياك الله خليني اسال اولا عن
خدمات النقل الترددي بالحفلات اللي موجوده
على منفت سلوى وهي تنقل طبعا الجماهير
المسافرين وغيرهم همم
المونديال وخصوصا بعد نهايه المراحل
الاولى والغاء اشتراط الدخول بهايه وايضا
كمان جواز السفر هل تغيرت هذه الخدمات او
لازاله كما هي في نفس مستوى مشاركه
المنتخب السعودي عندما كان موجود البطوله
حياك الله اخي نايف شكرا لكم على هذه
الاستضافه والتطرف لهذا الموضوع المهم
اللي يبرز دور الجهات الحكوميه والخاصه
المختلفه ذات العلاقه لتسعه لتوفير تجربه
اثريه للمشجع الراغب بزياره دوله قطر
والاستمتاع بمونديال كاس العالم في دوله
قطر هذا المدير الاستثنائي من كل النواحي
من الجانب التنظيمه وايضا من جانب نتائج
نتائج
اليوم الهيئه العامه للنقل انطلاقا من
دورها في الاستراتيجي في تحفيز استخدام
وسائل النقل العام وايضا في التاكد من جوز
الخدمات المقدمه للمستفيدين من الخدمات
النقل العام همم شاركت مع جهاز الحكوميه
ذات العلاقه في همم فعاليه كاس العالم في
دوله قطر 2022 من توفيق خدمات النقل في
ثلاث مواقع رئيسيه او ثلاث رئيسيه تتكلم
عن الموقع الاول منفذ سلوى المنفذ البري
اللي يربط دوله قطر بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه هناك 55 حافله مجهزه على مدار
الساعه وهيئه لاستقبال مشجعين ونقلهم
تردديا بين منفذ سلوى في الجانب السعودي
وايضا همم الى منفذ ابو سمره في الجانب
القطري ايضا هناك عشر رحلات مجانيه من
محافظه الاحساء في مدينه التمور في محافظه
الاحساء حتى همم
منفذ سلوى في الجانب السعودي وايضا يمكن
يشجع باستمرار باستخدام الحافلات نقل تردد
داخل دوله قطر تكلم برده هناك خدمات همم
الاجره من مدينه الدمام وايضا من محافظه
احسن هناك ايضا تطبيقات نقل الركاب من
الدمام محافظه الاحساء هناك ايضا خدمات
اخرى في ثلاث مدن رئيسيه رياضه جدول
الدمام لنقل نشجعين من الى المطارات
ممتازه على الذكر الحفلات في الفتره
الماضيه وخصوصا في خلينا نقول مباريات دور
الثمانيه اللي هي كانت مباريات حاسم وفيها
الارجنتين وفيها البرازيل في تشوق كبير من
الجماهير انها تذهب الى قطر وشفنا عدد
كبير جدا في المنطقه وكان الحديث على انه
الحافلات الموجوده في المنفذ لا تتناسب مع
عدد الجماهير الموجوده هنا لا اركب اللوم
على احد لكن انا اقول ايضا حتى ممكن من
البعض اللي حضر اللي همم المنفذ انه همم
الاشتراطات او ما اعرف عنها ايضا فبالتالي
كان في عدد كبير موجود كيف بتتعملوا مع
حاله زياده هذه خلينا نتكلم اليوم في
اقبال كبير عالي جدا من المشجعين مثل ما
ذكرت خاصه في همم منافسات الربع النهائي
وايضا اليوم وبكره كمان استعداد همم
نصف النهائي هناك قبال الكبير على خدمه
نقل تردد في منفذ سلوى اكثر 250,000 همم
مستفيده وراكب استفاد من الخدمات مندوب
بالانطلاق مونديال كاس العالم في دوله قطر
2022 من خلال 7000 رحله مجانيه نقلت
المشجعين بين المنفذ 7000 رحله حتى الان
خلال 20 يوم نتكلم يوم انطلاقه البطوله
7,000 رحله استفادونها 250,000 راكب كان
هناك اقبال كثيف وعالي خلال نهايه الاسبوع
الماضي التزامنه مع مناسبه منافسات ربع
النهائي استفاد من يوم الجمعه فقط وحده
اكثر من 42,000 راكب استفاد من هذه
الخدمات هناك همم رغبه كامله لتلبيه جميع
المطلقات وايضا تقديم رحله سلسه وثريه
للمشجع لذلك نؤكد على اهميه حجز الرحله من
خلال حجز المجاني للرحله من خلال الموقع
الالكتروني المشهور في منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي الي هي اللي مضمن له المشجع
رحله سلسه الى داخل دوله باختصار في وسائل
نقل اخرى غير الحافلات التردديه هناك
اليوم مثل ما ذكرنا
تنقل من محافظه الاحساء مدينه الدمام ايضا
هناك تطبيقات نقل الركاب من محافظه
الاحسان الى الدمام واكد على الحفلات
التجاريه الموجوده في مدينه التمور في
محافظه الاشكرك جزيلا شكرا على حضورك معي
هنا في استدي نشات الرابع متحدث باسم هذه
العمل انك
رابع مستمره بعد قليل
هيئه العقاري في السعوديه تعلن عن ارتفاعا
منصات العقاريه بضوابط الاعلانات ومعايير
الترخيص
حياكم الله من جديد كشفت الهيئه السعوديه
للعقار عن ارتفاع نسبه امتثال المنصات
العقاريه الالكترونيه
المخالفه لضوابط ومعالجتها اما بتعديل
المحتوى او بازالته بما يحفظ حقوق
المتعاملين في السوق العقاري ويعزيز جوده
الخدمات العقاريه
كده وزير البيئه والمياه والزرا عبد
الرحمن الفضل ان الطلب على المياه سيرتفع
الى ثمانيه عشره مليون متر مكعب يوميا
بحلول 20 30 مشيرا الى ان 65% من المياه
المحله في السعوديه تنتجها المؤسسه العامه
لتحليه المياه المالحه والقطاع الخاص
[موسيقى]
هرت بيانات وصادره عن وزاره الاستثمار
السعوديه تسجيل زياده سنويه في عدد السياح
الوافدين خلال الربع الثاني من العام
الجاري باكثر من
570% ليتجاوز عددهم ثلاثه ملايين ونصف
مليون سائح بينما ارتفع عدد السياح
المحليين بنسبه 42 و3 من 10% خلال الفتره
نفسها بيان الوزاره كشف عن ارتفاع نسبه
انفاق السياحه الوافدين ب 570% في الربع
الثاني ليصل الى
15.7 مليار ريال كما زاد الانفاق السياحي
المحلي بنسبه 31 ونصف في المئه في نفس
الفتره الى 22.7 مليار الوزاره كشفت عن
تسير اكثر من سته ملايين السائح من الخارج
من الاصلي سته واربعين مليون سائحين اجنبي
ومحلي خلال النصف الاول من العام الحالي
ضمنها فعاليات موسم رياضه 2022 اقيمت في
مسرح ابو بكر سالم سهره طلبيه تضمنت
معزوفات غنائيه من الحان الفنان المصري
الراحل محمد عبد الوهاب الليله الكلاسيكيه
تزامنت مع الاجواء الشتويه التي تشهدها
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وضمت 80 عازفا
بقياده المايسترو نادر عباسي الذي افتتح
الحفله بمعزوفه الراحل ثلاثه وصلات غنائيه
متنوعه لابرز الحاني عبد الوهاب
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابع بابرزي عناوينها
حكومه افغانستان تنتعوا علينا ومقتله
ثلاثه مهاجمين واصابات في صفوف في اجانب
في الهجوم على فندق يضم صينيين
خطط لانشاء رئيس شركه الصناعات العسكريه
السعوديه يقول بان التركيز القادم سيكون
للمسيرات والردرات
مركز الرصاد في السعوديه وصلوا تحضيره من
استمرار الفرصه طول امطار غزيره على مكه
وجده
شكرا لكم